[Music]
two years ago Madame Tussauds made a wax
likeness of me
and they finished it and the statue was
supposed to be displayed at Universal
Studios in Los Angeles for the next 600
years obviously things didn't work out
and I kind of forgot about the wax
Madame Tussauds statue and then just a
couple of like about two weeks ago we
said hey whatever happened to that thing
and someone asked it turns out the wax
statue of me has been returned to Madame
Tussauds Wax Museum on Hollywood
Boulevard which isn't far from here
now I was curious I've been through a
lot the last 18 months and I thought
it'd be really interesting kind of
fascinating to visit the wax statue and
reconnect with the Conan of two years
ago she seemed like it'd be fascinating
opportunities so one of Madame Tussauds
employees named Adam me deaf showed me
around and we took a camera crew here's
what happened
[Music]
okay this is weird this is really weird
you guys have gotten rid of the talk
show - no you stuck me on a bench and
I'm all by myself and it looks weird I'm
looking at Nicolas Cage's ass yeah then
I'm telling Simon Cowell about it who's
not impressed yeah this is a weird
tableau here we have the name plates
yeah Nicolas Cage Simon Cowell fire exit
sign where is Conan oh there's no corner
Brian sign first of all you need a
notable quote like Nicolas Cage has to
be a good actor you have to be something
like criminal to be willing to break the
rules oh yeah here's Mike here's my
quote I'd like a frickin plan okay
that's what you say that in Spanish
that's the other thing we need a yo
quiero wouldn't freaking plac found this
Yeah right there is a plaque there is so
how come it's not up we thought you
should do the honors for it Wow
what do you mean you're early yeah we
have a karna plaque we should probably
get to that well anyway later yeah
how about just covering Nicolas Cage
that's pretty good yeah would you like
to know a fun fact about your date of
birth yeah on the day you were born
NBC aired Truth or Consequences The
Price is Right the match game and you
don't say ABC aired beat the clock and
CBS aired password it to tell the truth
I can tell you the game shows that aired
when you were born for any date that you
give me May 5th 1977 May 5th 1977 CBS
aired tattletales they aired match game
77 there'd the price is right
NBC aired the Hollywood Squares the gong
show and ABC aired Family Feud and the
$20,000 pyramid June 9th 1986 June 9th
1986 CBS aired card sharks the $25,000
pyramid press your luck was skill on the
air but kind of limping towards the
finish line and
and on CBS the help it's a gift
is it some people raising all right okay
why are you making these circles were
you from you're from South Korea okay
very nice to see you you don't even know
who I am though do you I'm an American
star
not so big what American stars do you
know what what's that
Joey Italy Rizzoli yeah very beautiful
yes yes she and I were lovers one time
but she was yeah yeah
she was with me I was very sad
yeah you want to see my statue now you
want to see my money right over there
that's me look
[Applause]
no pictures
I see you later see you later bye bye
see you later
before I go I thought I'd uh update my
statue a little bit I've been through a
lot in the last year and a half and want
this guy to neglect this going we go
pretty nice
kind of
[Applause]
good luck